Qui présente comment ça se passe ?
Allez !
Faut dire quoi déjà ?
Tu peux faire "Salut..."
Salut !
Bienvenue dans cette vidéo où on va doubler un film.
Salut et bienvenue dans cette vidéo où on va doubler un film.
Vous connaissez Sofyan ?
Il fait ça souvent sur sa chaîne.
Regardez son entrée est incroyable.
Vous connaissez Sofyan ? Je fais ça souvent sur ma chaîne.
On va expliquer quand même le concept avant de lancer le film.
On met un film...
Là en l'occurence c'est le film Scarface.
Et on va doubler en totale improvisation le film.
Qui a vu le film ?
Moi je l'ai vu !
En 6ème 3.
Vous avez tous vu le film ?!
Alors moi c'était quand j'étais en 6ème, en vrai...
C'était un an après Les Visiteurs.
94 hein...
Je sais pas si tu...
Ouais, non j'étais pas là.
J'existais pas encore sur cette planète mec.
Je t'entendais.
C'est vrai ?
Oui !
Quelle année ?
95.
Ah mais il t'entendait.
Mais je t'endendais.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais, je te...
Je te checkais, je faisais attention à tout ce que tu disais.
C'est parti.
Attention.
On y va ?
Ouais.
On y va !
Non.
D'accord.
Prénom.
Ah d'accord, ok.
Je croyais que tu répondais "non". Nom, ok.
Non, non, c'étais pas une négation.
Ok mon nom c'est Pascal.
Pascal ok ?
Et ça c'est quoi ?
Ça c'est un petit coeur.
Un petit coeur ? Tu te fous de moi ?
Tu t'appelles Scarface.
Le mec il a pas d'imagination.
Tu t'appelles Scarface, comme le titre du film.
Tu t'appelles le nom du film !
Ça veut rien dire ce que tu me dis.
Nan, écoute moi...
C'est comme si Matrix s'appelait Matrix.
Neo s'appelait Matrix.
Que le vélociraptor s'appelait Jurassic Park.
Que... Woody s'appelait Toy Story.
Que...
Ça a un sens, ça a un sens tout ça, désolé.
Que Jack s'appelait Titanic. Lâchez moi les mecs !
Lâchez moi !
J'ai plus de couilles que tous les flics réunis.
Ok ?
Et je peux continuer de parler de couille.
Parce que je m'y connais en couille.
Ah t'as les boules !
Eh couille, t'as les boules, t'as les glandes.
Ouais, ouais, les crottes de nez qui pendent.
Je la connais, je la finis avant toi. Qu'est c'qu'y a ?
Enfoiré de condé. Ouais, ouais.
Si je veux, je suis policier moi.
Qu'est ce qu'il faut pour être flic hein ? Il faut le brevet ?
Et bah je l'ai pas.
Eh, regarde, tu veux que je te dise un truc ?
Je t'attrape dans la rue, je te nique ta race.
Eh si on se revoit dans la rue, je te nique ta race !
Regarde je te... Moi... Moi je te défonce.
Je te défonce tellement, tellement que... EH !
Salut looser !
J'ai le meilleur des débardeurs.
Ok !
C'est Mani.
Wow ! Bachata ! Salsa !
Des débardeurs !
Qu'est ce qu'ils ont avec cette folie des débardeurs ?
Je comprends pas !
Il faut que tu lui dises à Tony.
Ouais.
A Pascal pardon, excuse moi.
Ouais dis moi ?
C'est qu'il pense qu'il a un débardeur mais c'est un putain de tablier qu'il porte.
Il a l'air con !
C'est pas ça un débardeur, je te le dis !
Tu te crois malin toi avec ton...
Ton col...
Ton...
Ton col... Ton...
Ton col y dépasse de tous les côtés.
Mon col ?
Et toi avec les cheveux en arrière, comme si...
Comme si tu t'étais...
Tu parles à qui là ? Tu sais que j'ai un couteau ?
Ouais bah moi j'ai des débardeurs. J'en ai 3.
T'as pas de débardeur !
J'en ai 3... J'en ai...
Je peux en avoir 4 !
Eh écoute, laisse le.
C'est un tablier que t'as mec !
T'es aveugle ou quoi ?
T'as l'air con mec !
Dis pas que t'as un débardeur si t'as un tablier !
C'est la moindre des choses.
Ok bah toi tu te la fermes et je te casse la bouche.
Ok ?
Tu portes un putain de tabler, dis le !
Je veux t'entendre le dire.
Dis "j'ai un tablier".
Allez.
Dis le, bordel de merde, dis le !
J'ai un débardeur. Ok ?
C'est pas grave, je pense que c'est un débardeur taille XL.
Ouais mais toi tu m'as dit que c'était un débardeur.
T'es vraiment un enfoiré.
Je passe pour un con devant eux.
Ecoute !
Pourquoi vous vous disputez ?
Eh garde le ton débardeur !
Pourquoi tu le jettes ?
Oh !
Mec je t'ai offert...
Oh, eh ! Ecoutez moi, je m'en prendre...
Va te faire enculer !
C'est ça ouais. Je vais m'acheter un vrai débardeur.
Vas-y !
Fais pas gaffe, tant pis.
C'est ça ouais. Je vais m'acheter un vrai débardeur.
Maintenant on se foutra plus de ma gueule.
Moi je vends pas des vrais débardeurs moi ?
Moi je vends pas des vrais débardeurs ?!
Je sais pas ce qu'on doit faire mais j'ai un plan.
Vous m'écoutez ?
Ok. On y va.
Ok !
Am, stram, gram, pic et pic et colé ?
Fuck you mon gars !
Fuck you !
Oh je t'emmerde !
Ça fait bien plaisir de vous voir. Bienvenue à vous !
Ça va, ça va.
Alors comme ça vous portait plus de débardeur, vous avez lâché l'affaire ?
Ça tombe bien parce qu'ici c'est les chemises.
C'est le royaume de la chemise !
Ok ok, tu me parles là.
Ça me fait plaisir de vous voir les gars.
Je te présente Mani.
Salut !
Il a une cravate.
Je déteste les cravates, est-ce qu'il peut l'enlever ?
Il peut l'enlever ou pas ?
J'ai demandé une fois, si je demande une deuxième fois ça va me vénère.
Il peut enlevé sa cravate ? C'est possible ?
Après...
Tu nous aimes comme on est ou comme tu veux qu'on soit.
Tu crois que je vous aime ?
Non.
Il croit que je l'aime !
C'est un ouf lui ! Il croit que je l'aime !
Non mais...
Il veut que vous l'aimiez patron.
Non mais je demande, je...
Oh c'est trop un ouf !
J'ai dit ça comme ça.
Je t'accueille chez moi, j'ai pas dit que je t'aimais.
Faut peut-être pas s'emballer mec !
Non mais c'est une expression parce que lui il a une cravate.
Et que...
Ah putain ! Je te propose un verre mais t'emballe pas ça veut pas dire que je t'aime hein.
Tu veux boire quoi ?
Tu m'expliques pourquoi ils ont des chaussures ici ?
Pardon.
A l'intérieur.
Hein ?
Parce que...
Pourquoi ils ont des putains de chaussures ?
Parce que sinon tu sers à rien.
Faut bien que je te paye pour nettoyer un truc.
Moi je suis hyper propre.
C'est pour ça que j'invite des gens, juste pour qu'ils dégueulassent chez moi.
Sinon ma femme de ménage elle sert à rien.
Femme de ménage qui sert à rien.
Ah je te jure, putain.
Venez on va salir des trucs dans la cuisine.
Tu te souviens, on s'était vu dans l'ascenseur.
Je m'appelle Emilie.
D'acc... On s'est vu dans l'ascenseur.
Tu te rappelles ?
Je t'ouvre la porte.
C'est cool.
De rien hein...
Non mais c'est pas grave, je dis jamais merci moi aussi.
Ça nous fait un point commun.
Regarde, hop !
De rien !
Même avec moi...
Avec moi même je le fais.
1...
2, 3, 4, 5, ...
7, 8, 9, ...
10, 11, ...
Mais tu comptes quoi à la fin ? Bordel de merde.
T'as l'air de compter un truc...
Mais personne sait ce que c'est. On a l'air con en attendant.
Désolé les gars j'ai pas écouté le début.
A chaque fois qu'il prend une tomate il la mâche huit fois.
Non c'est faux ! Des fois...
Des fois... enfin je peux l'avaler direct.
Impossible.
J'ai fait tous mes calculs, ça fait...
3 mois que je te regardes genre...
Que je t'analyse tu vois, genre je...
Tu m'analyses ?
Mais t'es malade !
Mais ferme là putain.
Le provoque pas.
Non mais attends, tu... tu comptes mes mâchoires ?
Mais arrêtes...
Mais t'es fou.
Donc là tu comptes mes cheveux... Tu vas compter quoi après ?
Tu vas compter tous les débardeurs que j'ai ?
Parce que j'en ai pleins, j'en ai...
J'en ai... J'ai beaucoup de débardeurs.
Je t'ai parlé de tous les débardeurs que j'avais ?
Putain Pascal c'est quoi ton problème ?
Si il aime compter les trucs, il compte le trucs !
Pourquoi tout de suite tu fous...
Ah c'est bizarre. C'est bizarre mec !
On est venu faire du business avec le mec.
Et toi tu l'embrouilles comme ça.
On a tous nos TOC.
J'ai pas confiance.
Je veux dire, est-ce que moi je te fais chier parce que t'es à fond sur les débardeurs ?
J'ai pas confiance !
C'est génial !
Laisse le tranquille je t'ai dit !
Compte des trucs !
Fais genre t'es comme lui, compte des trucs !
Un citron...
T'es content ?
Oh putain !
Ça va ?
Ça va t'as fait... t'as fait 3 pas en là venant là.
Voilà ! Bien joué !
Bien joué Pascal !
On était en train de compter des trucs pendant que vous étiez pas là.
Ah putain !
Et qu'est ce que j'adore compter des trucs aussi !
Par exemple...
Euh avec Tony et toi...
On est 3 autour de la pièce.
Y a moi, on est 1.
Y a toi, on est 2.
Et 4, des fois...
Non Tony 3, putain, compte bien au moins !
Il sait pas compter aussi Tony, c'est ça le truc.
Tu sais ce n'est pas un TOC, c'est juste...
1, 2, 3, 4
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, ...
9670 tours/minute !
A toi de compter !
Regarde ! C'est impressionnant ! A toi de compter.
Oh putain !
Je vais mourir une fois !
Je le sens !
Oh putain !
Allez, un décès !
Oh merde.
J'ai pas eu le temps de compter.
Mais je dirai comme toi...
400...
464 !
Putain c'est le meilleur ça !
467 si je dois être plus précis... Mais t'es plus fort que moi à ce jeu hein.
Ça s'apprend pas le compter.
Ça s'apprend dès la naissance.
Mais faut s'entraîner.
Faut se réveiller le matin et se dire "Ah...
Une journée...
7 jours dans la semaine", enfin faut compter tout le temps quoi !
Et toi tu l'as ce truc.
Toi t'es...
C'est là où je t'admire tu vois !
Tu m'as pas répondu à la question tout à l'heure.
Quel âge as-tu Pascal ?
34, allez.
Non, je sais pas...
Après si il faut...
Parce qu'on a pas la même manière de compter je pense.
Je veux pas te vexer, je te dis 34 mais...
Ça peut être 33.
Ça peut être...
Ça peut être 32.
Et tu sais quoi, ça peut être 8.
8, allez va pour 8.
J'ai 8 ans mec.
Là j'ai envie de regarder Gulli là.
Salut.
Bah alors Pascal qu'est ce que tu fous là ?
C'est marrant, je te croyais à Dijon.
Je t'ai manqué ou...
Ou pas du tout.
Parce que là je commence à me dire qu'on fait la fête sans moi quoi.
Et ça, ça me vexe un tout petit peu donc je vais m'installer.
Si ça vous dérange pas hein.
J'avoue que t'avais l'air un peu vénère, je comprenais pas pourquoi. C'est gentil de nous expliquer.
Mais c'est pas vraiment une fête, c'est improvisé...
Y a Romain qu'est passé au hasard...
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais...
Et puis y avait déjà Stéphane qui était là.
Et c'est pas vraiment une soirée organisée sinon on t'aurait appelé tu penses bien !
Ouais...
Le prend pas comme ça Pascal !
Tu sais bien qu'à chaque fois qu'on fait une soirée Fifa, on t'appelle !
D'accord... ouais...
Et pourquoi y a un événement Facebook ?
Si c'est pas organisé.
Ah tu me prends un peu au dépourvu là.
C'est pas moi qui...
Dépourvu ?
Non je t'ai pas demandé de...
Bon je sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais...
Mais y a quand même un événement Facebook.
T'arrive pile à l'heure ! Qu'est ce que tu casses les couilles.
T'as rien raté de la soirée !
Alors pourquoi vous rigoliez avant que j'arrive ?
Parce qu'on était mort de rire parce que je faisais une blague au téléphone.
Je me suis auto-feinté.
J'ai fait genre je raccrochais alors qu'en fait je raccrochais pas.
J'ai un humour particulier mais tant que ça blesse personne...
J'aime pas l'humour communautaire.
Je fais juste des blagues téléphoniques.
Regarde par exemple là je vais faire genre j'ai quelqu'un en ligne...
Alors qu'y a personne. Allo ?
Allo oui, je voudrais commander une marguerite.
Alors que ça n'existe même pas comme pizza.
Pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas ?
Parce que ça n'existe pas ?
Bon...
C'était pas la meilleure blague !
Mais moi ça me fait rire !
Ouais, ouais...
Toi ça te fait pas rire, je peux comprendre.
Tu me dis qu'il ne s'est rien passé du tout.
Et je vois que tu as fait des blagues téléphoniques.
T'as un humour hyper pointu mais moi j'ai un humour de merde !
Tu sais que j'aime bien les blagues téléphoniques.
Ah ouais ?
Fais moi en une tout de suite.
J'ai plus d'idée de blague téléphonique.
J'avais 2 idées, j'ai fait les 2.
Et elles étaient déjà pas ouf !
Si j'en fais une troisième ça va être la honte.
Elle va vraiment être claquée, je le sens.
J'ai pas beaucoup d'inspi en blague téléphonique.
Comme pas hasard !
D'abord l'événement Facebook...
Maintenant plus d'idées de blague !
Alors qu'il existe...
Au moins...
1, 2, 3, ...
Je sais plus, au moins...
Au moins 9 blagues, je pense.
Je peux refaire une blague que j'ai déjà faite.
Mais y aura plus l'effet de surprise.
L'effet de surprise ça marche toujours.
Par exemple...
Les Visiteurs 1, tout le monde était surpris !
Alors que Les Visiteurs 2...
Tout le monde savait déjà que...
Tu vois ? Que c'est des mecs du Moyen Age.
Dans le présent.
C'est beaucoup moins surprenant, du coup les gens ont moins aimé !
Tu veux vraiment être déçu Pascal ?
Allo ?
C'est Sarah. Sarah qui ?
Ça raccroche.
Ça va ? Ça vous va Pascal ?
Je l'ai pas là.
C'est qui ? C'est Sarah.
Ça rappelle.
Je connais pas de Sarah.
Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
Non !
Putain !
Mec !
Je tente une vanne quoi, je sais pas...
Oh putain !
Allo ?
Vas-y, vas-y, continue !
Ça, ça, ça, attends !
Deux secondes...
Sarah, Sarah...
Croche, j'ai déjà fait...
Un autre prénom !
Un autre prénom genre Miranda.
Allez ! Essaye !
Essaye Miranda au téléphone !
Elle a pas le téléphone Miranda peut-être ?
Allo ?
C'est qui ? C'est Miranda.
Ouais ?
Vas-y continue. Qu'est ce qu'elle fait Miranda ?
Miranda !
C'est qui ? Dis moi qui c'est !
Tu me dis qu'il y a quelqu'un au téléphone et tu me dis pas qui c'est.
Ça me saoule !
Oh putain !
Allo ?
Mais il croit qu'on a inventé le haut parleur en 70 ou quoi ?
Putain, dis moi ce qu'il dit !
J'ai quelque chose à vous dire de très important Pascal.
Vous n'avez pas 8 ans.
J'ai appelé votre maman...
Il dit qu'il a appelé votre maman.
Votre maman m'a dit quelque chose de très imp...
Tenez je vous le...
Ouais, ouais, ouais, j'entends en fait, y a le haut parleur.
J'avais pas compris.
Merci, merci.
Ok.
Vous m'entendez Pascal ?
Oui j'entends ! T'es con ou quoi, je t'entends !
Je te...
Mais il... Putain !
Ça marche ou ça marche pas !
Calmez vous, calmez vous, calmez vous !
Elle est où la garantie ? Trouvez moi le ticket de caisse !
Trouve moi le ticket de caisse !
Calmez vous, j'ai pas, j'ai pas.
Faut trouvez le ticket de caisse !
Tu sais ce que je vais faire Pascal ?
Je vais te racheter tous tes débardeurs.
Ah vas-y, j'ai plus envie.
Je vais te les racheter Pascal !
Pascal je vais te les racheter !
Je vais te les ra...
J'ai pas envie ! J'ai...
J'ai envie de les garder. Tu sais quoi ? Je vais...
Je vais... Je vais les vendre moi !
Ah ouais, tu vas les vendre toi ?
Je vais les vendre moi.
Et je vais me faire un max de pognon.
Parce que le débardeur c'est...
C'est bien.
C'est bien !
J'assume maintenant.
Pascal se braque.
Le cours du débardeurs a chuté.
Ça ne coûte plus rien du tout.
C'est des conneries, moi je veux en vendre des débardeurs.
Ouais ! J'vous le dis !
Je vais mettre des diamants dedans et...
Les gens vont les acheter c'est sûr.
Ça va revenir.
Un débardeur coûterait le prix d'un immeuble.
C'est la news extraordinaire.
Cet immeuble...
Voudrait un débardeur.
Bah voilà !
Oh !
Je te parle !
Y a pas de je te parle qui tienne.
Roh putain.
Y a pas de je te parle qui tienne ?
Tu sais ce qui tient ?
C'est les...
Les murs de la maison !
Eh ouais, et les murs de toutes les maisons du monde !
Allez Pascal !
Je te laisse, je me barre.
Je vois que t'as envie de profiter simplement de ton petit truc à toi tout seul.
Te baigner tout seul. T'as pas voulu... Tu m'as même pas proposé de me baigner mec.
T'as changé !
Parce que t'es jaloux de mon maillot de bain Pascal.
Maillot de bain ?
T'es jaloux de mon maillot de bain, si tu le voyais là tu serais jaloux.
Pourquoi je peux pas rentrer dans l'eau Pascal, dis moi ?
Pourquoi tu me laisse pas rentrer ?
Dis moi pourquoi est-ce que je peux pas être là ?
T'es là devant ta télé, à te la raconter !
Si tu rentres c'est à poil enculo !
A poil ?
Oui à poil, tu crois que je suis habillé moi ?
Attends mais je vais pas venir à poil alors que j'ai un super maillot de bain Pascal !
Putain ! Qu'est c'tu me fais ! Merde !
Putain tu comprends rien à la mode, je me casse !
Ouais c'est ça !
Et les murs y tiennent hein !
Ça je l'ai dit, je le répéterai toute ma vie !
Que je sois seul ou pas !
Bande d'enfoirés !
C'est la fin de cette vidéo !
J'espère que ça vous aura plu !
Je vous rappelle également...
Qu'on a fait une vidéo doublage sur le film Sin City.
Sur la chaîne YouTube, la mienne.
Donc, vous pouvez y aller.
Abonnez-vous si cette vidéo vous a plu.
On est sur la chaîne de Golden Moustache.
Ouais.
Abonnez-vous à cette chaîne si cette vidéo vous a plu.
Je crois ouais.
On est avec Multiprise.
Abonnez-vous à cette chaîne.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu !
A très vite.
On se retrouve...
Faut que tu remettes l'objectif sur la caméra.
Vas-y, vas-y attends.
A très vite !